und das bedienen ist uns der
bundesgesundheitsminister zugeschaltet
hallo herr spahn
schönen guten abend slomka wir haben
jetzt august die reisewelle rollt schon
länger warum kommen diese test
verpflichtungen erst jetzt das ist ein
bisschen spät
wichtig ist ja frau slomka es gibt seit
monaten die wichtige regelung dass
rückkehrer und ein reisender aus
risikogebieten zwei wochen in quarantäne
müssen das gilt ja auch noch fort das
ist eine wichtige schutzmaßnahme und
gleichzeitig sehen wir mit jetzt
steigendem risiko reiseverkehr vor allem
eben aus risikogebieten macht die
testpflicht auch sinn zusätzlich und die
haben wir jetzt auch zügig umgesetzt
bevor die europäische union auch über
weitere lockerungen für risikoländer
außerhalb der eu diskutiert im übrigen
ist mein eindruck die allermeisten
bürgerinnen und bürger wollen sich auch
sogar gerne testen lassen
da geht es gar nicht nur um eine pflicht
sondern viele sehen auch für sich selbst
darin ein stück sicherheit man kann sich
dem aber auch ziemlich leicht entziehen
wenn man will und bei autoreisen wird es
dann sowieso nur noch sporadisch da
stimmt es ist natürlich gerade bei den
landgrenzen am ende nur ein stichproben
möglich das zu testen aber es gibt heute
schon
auch das ist vielen gar nicht so bewusst
die verpflichtung dass wenn ich einreise
aus einem risikogebiet ich mich mal bei
meinem gesundheitsamt vor ort am wohnort
am zielort melden muss das bleibt auch
weiterhin der fall und wie gesagt wer
kein negativ test hat wenn ich getestet
wird oder sich nicht testen lässt der
muss auch weiterhin zwei wochen in
quarantäne oder eine strafe zahlen da wo
zudem testen aufgefordert wird und dann
dem nicht nachgekommen wird genau da
sieht das infektionsschutzgesetz ein
bußgeld vor wie eben für andere
regelungen man kann man sich fragen wie
sinnvoll ist es nur diese risikogebiete
zu testen so man sich wehren achten alle
regeln hält ist man wahrscheinlich in
luxemburg lama auf risiko weitaus
weniger gefährdet als banner auf party
auf mallorca sage ich mal salopp
deswegen haben wir zusätzlich seit
letzten samstag die möglichkeit für alle
einreisenden aus allen ländern
tatsächlich sich kostenlos testen zu
lassen
auch das ist eine schutzmaßnahme wir
haben im moment auch in dieser
sommerzeit die ausreichenden test
kapazitäten für ein solches angebot und
auch dort sehen wir dass sehr viele
bürger
und bürger von diesem angebot gebrauch
machen machen wollen
das geht an den flughäfen an den helfen
bahnhöfen zum teil aber es gibt eben
auch an testzentren die und da bin ich
der erste schafft sehr dankbar jetzt
auch wieder alle eröffnet werden wieder
in betrieb genommen werden um diese
tests möglich zu von der ärzteschaft hat
man aber dass das für ziemliche
organisatorische probleme sorgt also zum
beispiel auch bei hausärzten die jetzt
auch noch nachweisen sollen dass jemand
aus dem risikogebiet kommen und sagen
dass wir wollen auch eigentlich diese
leute die gar nicht bei uns einfach so
in den wartezimmern jetzt wieder alle
sitzen haben
das ziel ist ja auch tatsächlich das
nicht der einzelne einfach unangekündigt
zum arzt geht sondern dass auch
telefonisch ankündigt oder noch besser
idealerweise über 11 6 11 7 die
verfügbare telefonnummer auch der
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen sich
meldet und dann zu einem testzentrum
auch entsprechend verwiesen wird wo dann
ja auch viele über den tag getestet
werden die sich eben ausschließlich aufs
testen konzentrieren das hält dann auch
die arztpraxen von dem von dem
testbetrieb sozusagen weitestgehend frei
das ganze geschieht ja auch vor dem
hintergrund steigender zahlen auch durch
reiserückkehrer aber nicht nur wie sehen
sie diese situation insgesamt stehen wir
vor dieser sogenannten zwei siege mögen
dieses wort nicht aber es hat sich so
eingebürgert zweiten welle
ich mag dessen frau slomka der inbegriff
der zweiten welle nicht weil das so
suggeriert jetzt kommt wieder was das
wieder vorbei wir müssen uns daran
gewöhnen dass dieses virus dauerhaft mit
uns ist dass wir unseren alltag mit
diesem virus gestalten und gestalten
lernen und wir sehen ja wir sind noch
mitten in der pandemie in nord in
südamerika in vielen ländern der welt
ist das virus mehr denn je unterwegs die
zahlen steigen und wir sehen auch in
deutschland immer wieder ausbrüche
übrigens immer einen bestimmten
nachvollziehbaren settings umständen wie
die familienfeier wo ausgelassen
gefeiert wird wie die religiöse
zusammenkunft wo miteinander gesungen
wird im geschlossenen raum und man
vielleicht auf bestimmte regeln nicht
achtet wie bestimmte arbeitsabläufe wie
in den schlachthöfen also es gibt
eigentlich nur bestimmte situationen wo
wir es diesem virus eben schwerer machen
könnten als es dann manchmal im alltag
doch gelingt und ich finde maske
abstand halten hygieneregeln das alles
ist im vergleich zu dem was wir den
letzten monaten schon erleben mussten in
deutschland und europa eigentlich habe
die mittel die interessante frage ist ja
ab wann muss man dann doch wieder
stärkere beschränkungen ergreifen um
eben all das zu verhindern was man ja
auch am anfang dieser pandemie
verhindern wollte dass manche leute
sagen ja auch naja das jetzt die zahlen
steigen
das liegt am meer testungen aber die
zahl der der anteil der gestiegenen test
steht in keinem verhältnis zum anstieg
der bestehenden neuinfektion also das
kann's ja nicht sein sondern es gibt
offenbar eine größere ausbreitung lieder
oder nur ein teil der testungen führt
natürlich hat auch zu dazu dass wir das
dunkelfeld erhellt dass wir mehr
infektionen erkennen das ist ja auch gut
aber ja mit dem alltag auch mit dem
urlaubs alltag ich möchte viele ist das
jetzt auch die belohnung die urlaubszeit
nach entbehrungsreichen monaten und
gerade im urlaub sei tag das kennen wir
alle ist man auch mal ausgelassene ob
jetzt in deutschland oder im ausland
und dann müssen wir immer wieder aufs
neue eben an abstand halten hygiene
alltags maske erinnern ich verstehe auch
dass manch einer auch ermüdet ist ein
stück und sagt wie lange geht das noch
aber ich kann immer wieder nur aufs neue
sagen die maske zu tragen auch wenn es
manchmal nervt ist im zweifel das
mildere mittel zu einem anderen art und
das ist das entscheidende schützt einen
selbst und die anderen aber ab wann sagt
die bundesregierung das können wir jetzt
so moment nicht weiterlaufen mit allem
möglichen wieder geöffnet und auch vor
allem schulen geöffnet sein jetzt werden
die zahlen kritisch moment sind wir in
jedem fall noch in einer größenordnung
mit denen das gesundheitswesen und der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst umgehen
kann
in der kontaktpersonen nachfolge die
intensiv kapazitäten die intensivbetten
sind mehr als ausreichend stand heute
vorhanden
aber wir bleiben dem aufmerksam was
jetzt auch die weitere dynamik angeht
wenn wir uns jetzt stabilisieren auf
einem bestimmten niveau nun können wir
damit umgehen wenn die zahlen weiter
steigen dann kommt es auf uns alle an
im alltag aufeinander zu achten und im
weitere maßnahmen tatsächlich auch nicht
nur designer steigender schon
also wir sind ja schon in einer
situation steigender zahlen doch noch
mal die frage ab wann sagen sie
jetzt müssen wir wieder eigentlich in so
einer art lockdown dazu erst einmal
würde man ist sicherlich deutlich
differenzierter machen können auch mit
den erkenntnissen die wir haben als es
im märz notwendig war
es würde man sich hätte ich vor allem
auch wie auf regionale maßnahmen erst
mal konzentrieren wie wir es in
gütersloh ja auch gesehen haben zum
beispiel oder auch in offenbach ja
maßnahmen wieder lokal der kontakt
beschränkung ergriffen worden sind und
wir sehen eben ich habs gerade schon
gesagt es gibt bestimmte zusammenhänge
vor allem veranstaltungen
feierlichkeiten gesellig sein
das wird mit sicherheit der hauptfokus
jeder maßnahmen ob regional oder darüber
hinaus seien
dass man nochmal das einkaufen mit maske
einschränken muss das sehe ich nicht
aber eine konkrete zahlen haben sie
nicht es gab mal zeiten da wurden
konkrete zahlen genannt
ja ich finde das schwierig mit den
konkreten zahlen weil es immer nicht es
gibt nicht die eine zahl das ist glaube
ich wichtig auch um vertrauen zu
erhalten und es immer wieder zu erklären
die eine zahl auf die alles reduziert
werden kann
es gibt den steigerungsfaktor also um
wie viel dynamischer wird das
infektionsgeschehen es gibt die absolute
zahl der infektionen mit um die 1000
neuinfektionen pro tag kann das
gesundheitswesen umgehen und wichtig
sind dann vor allem auch die kapazitäten
im gesundheitswesen wie viel
intensivbetten haben wir zur verfügung
können wir alle behandeln und das kann
man nicht auf eine zahl reduzieren
sondern das müssen wir und das tun wir
auch täglich wöchentlich immer wieder
aufs neue checken und vor allem dann
eben auch wo nötig maßnahmen vor allem
regional ergreifen ersparen danke für
das gespräch sehr gerne